c'est une nouvelle ère que ça prête à
connaître Miss France
[Applaudissements]
vont radicalement changer nouveau
critères d'âge de taille et même de sexe
la présidente du comité Alexia larol
Joubert entend bien des poussières et le
concours est-ce que si un homme qui est
devenu une femme et qui a un état civil
féminin peut participer au concours Nice
France j'ai répondu en tout cas il peut
parfaitement s'inscrire ouverture du
casting aux femmes transgenres mais
aussi aux femmes mariées ou mère de
famille même du côté des anciennes mises
ces nouvelles règles font débat c'était
mer de famille tu peux pas être Miss
France au quotidien cette impossible
alors tu ne vois pas ton enfant pendant
un an et les nouveautés du concours ne
s'arrêtent pas là il faut désormais
faire plus d'un mètre 70 les tatouages
sont acceptés et il n'y a plus de limite
d'âge pour se présenter Isabelle
Morini-Bosc a donc toutes ses chances
pas du tout j'en ai pas l'intention
suite aux différentes polémiques
criminatoires vous l'avez compris
aujourd'hui le concours Miss France se
veut progressiste et ouvert je plutôt
quelqu'un à l'écoute des changements de
société j'aime la modernité de
l'approche de ce concours tout en
préservant les fondamentaux pourtant
cette édition 2023 ne verra finalement
pas de candidats transgenres puisque
Andrea furet a été éliminé aux fortes
des demi-finales du concours missile de
France samedi dernier aux gens de me
connaître ou te raconter un peu plus mon
histoire samedi 17 décembre les Français
devront dire parmi les 30 prétendantes
celles qui succédera à Diane
[Musique]
alors on rappelle que les nouvelles
règles
les nouvelles règles effectivement on
peut aujourd'hui être âgé de plus de 18
ans mesurait au moins 1 m 70 c'est
désormais pour passer Miss France être
de sexe féminin à l'état civil
uniquement civile donc c'est la compote
tranche de réflexion si l'état civil et
féminin les candidats ne sont plus tenus
être célibataires voilà donc elles
peuvent même avoir accouché au tiroir
des enfants il était étoiles sont
désormais acceptés à savoir la question
qu'on se pose est-ce qu'on peut
finalement maintenant être tout ce qu'on
veut moche est une tranche je ne sais
pas mais donc effectivement transgenre
le débat alors je disais que Jean-Michel
toi tu faisais un peu alors un peu
Sardou non ça dépend je m'y connais pas
trop bien sur les transgenres est-ce que
30 jours ça veut dire qu'on est opéré ou
on peut être transgen sans être sûr on a
encore ses attributs masculins c'est
l'état civil qui a changé
quand même on peut être opéré un petit
peu de choisir on avait reçu quelqu'un
qui est étrangeant transgenre c'est que
effectivement tu as été
un homme tu es une femme officiellement
tu es une femme mais tu choisis après
toi de faire l'opération
on est devenu la température
encore les attributs d'un homme je suis
de la vieille génération ça me gênerait
d'élire une Miss France qui les
attributs d'un homme pourtant c'est une
question ça se passe là donc c'est pas
du tout l'État civils
est-ce que je peux on peut raconter ce
qui s'est vraiment passé parce que on a
vu là dans le sujet de façon très
subtile à l'excès à la rochebert qui dit
on peut courir en tout cas on peut
s'inscrire et en gros c'est ce qu'a vécu
Andrea furet pourquoi parce que dans
l'élimination la qualité la sienne il y
a quelques jours en fait c'est le public
il y a il y a un jury mais le public
vote ils étaient 1700 et il faut savoir
que le public c'est un peu une réponse à
la question qu'on se pose bah ils
avaient peut-être pas très envie qu'elle
se qualifie parce qu'ils ont voté en
masse contre elle contrairement
visiblement au jury qui était plutôt
favorable et ce qu'on m'a dit enfin ce
que je me suis laissé dire c'est que
beaucoup beaucoup de Miss ça se passe
comme ça dans les régions viennent avec
plein d'amis dans les 1700 toi tu peux
venir avec 45 potes et ils ont voté pour
toi
j'ai essayé de la contacter elle veut
plus parler elle est là elle veut plus
parler aux médias elle est elle est pas
super bien et elle regrette en fait que
son genre a été révélé avant en même
temps elle est contente parce que elle
représente quelque chose mais elle
aurait préféré que ce soit dit après le
calife donc on l'avait déjà vu voilà
elle est connue
aussi on disait qu'il y avait beaucoup
beaucoup de gens qui étaient là pour
voter en région à chaque fois c'est pour
ça qu'on avait autant de mises souvent
qui venait passer si c'était le jury
voilà mais là c'est plus de débat il est
plus sûr voilà 30 jours est-ce que c'est
possible ou pas un jour d'avoir une Miss
transgen il y en a une qui disent quand
même avec le comité maintenant a fait ça
parce que les Miss France c'est un petit
peu vieillissant faut relancer un petit
peu avec un buzz c'est ce qu'on a
demandé à l'excellaire au Joubert de
relancer un peu avec des buzz justement
il y a cette phrase que je vais quand
même vous lire et vous allez voir
Natacha c'est la phrase de notre ami bon
après elle est très mignonne donc elle a
un certain âge maintenant je n'ai le
Fontenay voilà ce qu'elle a déclaré
voilà chez vous une mise peut-être
lesbienne pourquoi pas tant qu'elle n'en
fait pas étalage c'est non mais c'est
voilà ce que je dis mais une Miss
transexuel pas question je suis plus
proche de la porte de sortie que de
l'entrée j'espère ne jamais voir ça de
même ma grand-mère que j'aimais
j'entendais pas ça c'est-à-dire
lesbienne j'espère que le montre pas
trop c'est quand hallucinant quand vous
entendez ça Natacha ou Déborah mais je
trouve qu'il y a il y a pas plus
représentatif du concours Miss France
que Geneviève de Fontenay donc en vrai
cette histoire de transexuel ou
transgenre en fait le public qui regarde
Miss France et entre guillemets pas tous
mais c'est un peu l'image de Geneviève
de Fontenay c'est un programme hyper
poussiéreux et les gens ne sont pas du
tout prêts ne sont pas une vieille dame
qui peut déplacer doucement doucement
comme un paquebot est-ce que voilà
est-ce qu'on va pas un peu trop vite
elle a ouvert la porte elle a ouvert la
porte déjà c'est pas la première année
directement maintenant il faut savoir
aussi c'est
Anna ou Anne jacapong qui vient
d'acheter le concours
très drôle ça et qui est également
transgen
exactement comme comme mademoiselle
Suray elles sont elles sont toutes les
deux absolument féminines physiquement
il n'y a pas on n'arrive pas à déc
quelque chose de virible masculin chez
elle quoi
que ce soit pas fait avant en fait je
trouve que Alexia large Joubert déjà
c'est une femme de conviction et qu'elle
a imposé ses convictions et je trouve ça
bien de moderniser le concours tous ces
tous ces sujets être maman à un peu plus
jeune à 30 ans à 20 ans c'est pas des
sujets être transgenres ça doit plus
être un sujet aujourd'hui et le fait que
le concours Miss France qui est quand
même un concours institutionnel bloqué
tout le monde à ce niveau là bah en fait
c'était de la régression pour moi de la
France au lieu d'être enfin d'aller de
l'avant et d'être de la modernité donc
c'est
les grosses dans ce cas là enfin pardon
moi je vais vous dire sur les sur les
transgenres c'est assez d'accord avec
toi en revanche sur toute l'ouverture
qu'il y a sur on peut on peut être un
peu pas très grand on peut être un petit
peu fort tard du 52 ce qui est un peu
agaçant c'est que on laisse entendre
qu'aujourd'hui tout le monde est beau or
beau pardon c'est un métier il y a des
gens qui font énormément de travail pour
être beau tu vois ce que je veux dire
qui mange qui vont tous ceux qui vont au
sport qui mais c'est plus récompensé ça
aussi quand j'en sais rien
excusez-moi il y a des femmes qui sont
en surpoids qui sont très belles c'est
horrible
qui aiment les femmes
et là ça allait dire à peu près la même
chose c'est il y a plein de filles qui
sont très curvi et qui sont très jolis
et après pour les transgenres je pense
que aujourd'hui c'est pas possible parce
que effectivement c'est une émission un
peu regarder par les vieux voilà à
partir de on va dire 50 60 ans mais en
revanche les jeunes les enfants nos
enfants transgenres pas transgenres ils
en ont rien à secouer c'est à dire
pourquoi c'est même pas un sujet c'est à
dire que dans leur école dans leur
classe maintenant aujourd'hui quand on a
voilà 15 ans les gens ils s'en foutent
mais complètement
quand tu leur dis je vous promets que
c'est vrai un jour j'ai dit non
t'es pas gai tu es mûres je m'en fous on
s'en fout je m'en fous tu es un garçon
une fille c'est pas un sujet il y a plus
de mots sur ce qu'on mettait nous euh
effectivement nous montrer du doigt moi
j'aime bien avoir quand même un avis
vous allez dire d'une autre époque Lolo
toi qui a dit sur TF1 toi qui regarde
les Miss France honnêtement je suis pas
fan du concours en général et je trouve
que de classer des femmes qui se
ressemblent globalement toutes pour
savoir quelle est la plus belle c'est
pas mon c'est pas mon style de beauté et
c'est pas genre le programme que je
regarde donc déjà one 2 que ça évolue
tant mieux mais il y a encore beaucoup
d'évolutions à faire ce qui est marrant
c'est de voir Elodie Gossuin qui dit par
exemple on peut pas être maman et être
Miss France c'est bizarre d'abord parce
qu'elle a cinq gosses et que elle sait
ce que c'est que la maternité et
justement c'est pour ça que et
deuxièmement quel bizarit de dire ça
c'est à dire que tu dirais n'importe
quelle femme qui fait un boulot qui
pendant un an la prend vachement tu as
pas le droit d'avoir d'enfant tu as le
droit pour la femme de quel droit
d'avoir une activité professionnelle qui
te prend beaucoup de temps et être maman
heureusement alors
bientôt
je suis tout à fait d'accord pour que ça
évolue déjà d'autres pays l'ont fait
avant nous on sait qu'on Espagne ça
existe depuis plus longtemps donc voilà
il y a pas de sujets pour moi là dessus
c'est vrai c'est que souvent d'ailleurs
il suffit de la France que c'est une
vieille dame faut souvent regarder ce
qui se passe en Espagne Belgique et vous
allez voir que 10 ans après on va
souvent faire la même chose que mais
juste deux mots
le principe de réalité c'est justement
parce qu'elle a quatre gosses et que
elle sait très bien que c'est infernal à
vivre pendant un an avec ses enfants
c'est le choix de la femme que vous
enfant de faire ou pas une activité
professionnelle c'est comme la dinde à
Noël pas forcément envie mais si on peut
enlève tu seras furieux et enfin en 3e
position il y a une vraie ambiguïté
parce que est-ce que Diane furet les
plus public la bloqué parce qu'elle est
transgenres ou tout simplement parce
qu'il l'a trouvé pas assez jolie il y
aura toujours cette ambiguïté sur cette
malheureusement les générations un petit
peu plus avec tout respect pour toi âgé
en disant elle a pris deux kilos et tout
le monde lui tomber dessus la pauvre
malheureuse
du concours il y a un symbole de ça
c'est même si je l'aime beaucoup et on
l'embrasse Jean-Pierre Foucault quel
animateur de Miss France c'est pas
l'animateur le plus jeune le plus
moderne et qui donne envie au concours
pour une passage il a rien compris non
non ce que je veux dire c'est que Miss
France il y a pas longtemps voici a dit
que Jean-Pierre Foucault allait dégager
Miss France c'est pas vrai c'est faux
non seulement il le garde mais en plus
il considère qui correspond à l'image du
concours donc ça répond à la question
c'est à dire que on n'est pas prêt le
public n'est pas prêt à élire un
transgenre fin janvier un peu ce que
disait Sophie disait que ses enfants
sont foutaient elle habite dans un bel
arrondissement parisien etc
dans un petit village de France etc
effectivement alors voilà c'est
peut-être moi alors ne vous engueulez
pas je vais conclure avec deux choses la
première d'abord Miss France c'est pour
tout le monde et au final c'est toujours
le public qui décide donc on verra bien
et en général le public en France
notamment ben souvent on dirait raciste
machin et tout et au contraire il fait
des très très bon choix donc c'est
public qui décidera et puis j'ai fini
par une petite vanne parce que j'aime
bien les anecdotes et vous savez que
vous êtes friands la meilleure vanne que
j'ai entendu cette année c'est quand
même Jean-Michel qui habite un quartier
de Paris que je ne dirais pas on peut
dire arrondissement ou pas mais dans le
15e son chien et les gens dans la rue la
reine tu lui disent vous prenez votre
chien il répond oh non c'est quoi la
vanne comme il est 10h45
[Applaudissements]
moi vous avez des quartiers non non pas
du tout c'est que mon chien ne pique que
dans le 15e moi j'habite plus tôt bon on
passe